[Music]
during the interview they were impressed
to see my experience and skills and they
were very much happy to see that I am
pursuing a course in digital Supply
Chain management which simply learn by
which they offered me a role of a senior
manager with a decent salary hike
hi I am Muhammad Abdul Wasim I am from
Bangalore
so I work in infinite marketing private
limited as senior manager in the
department of supply chain and Logistics
in the previous company I was working in
the field of operations actually I was
taking a care of operations as a branch
manager They promoted me in fact they
shifted me to a different department
altogether in a supply chain so to
enhance my knowledge and to know more
about this field I was looking for some
course so one of my friend actually
referred me to Simply learn wherein I
saw this curriculum and I thought that
this is a perfect one to actually
enhance and as well gain knowledge
the course has a blending the learning
method with which we can learn with our
own face and online classes are
conducted at the weekends so for working
professionals it is best suited
during the interview they were impressed
to see my experience and skills and they
were very much happy to see that I am
pursuing a course in digital Supply
Chain management which simply learn by
which they offered me a role of a senior
manager with a decent salary hike this
course has been a great add-on to my
professional expertise I can relate the
supply chain decisions day to day at
work
I believe that upskilling Journey with
simply learn has ignited a spirit of
learning in me which will help me
achieve my future goals
my career goal is to work at a senior
management position and use my
operational experience to benefit the
company
in free time I like to read books which
refreshes me and gives me knowledge
globally work environment is very
competitive so upskilling will help you
to stand out from the crowd
so gather your motivation and start your
upscaling journey now